america is scratching
[Music]
will the medical community crack down on
those who like to monkey around
does dr fauci think it's clever to make
us wear masks forever
the new ba 5 variant accounts for 65 of
positive covid cases and
hospitalizations seem to be up so guess
who's back it's america's favorite
doctor sorry dr drew
when you're in an area where you have a
high dynamic of infection and we're not
talking about mandating anything but
we're saying recommending people
when they are in indoor congregate
settings
to wear a mask
here we go again it's like that movie
about groundhog day
i forget what it's called
meanwhile next week the world health
organization will convene a second
emergency meeting to decide whether
monkey pox is a global health threat or
a distraction created by the bat soup
industry
damn them bastards
so far there are 9 200 confirmed cases
half of which can be traced back to one
person
[Music]
and from san francisco to new york city
the monkey pox vaccine is in short
supply as thousands line up to get the
jab interrupting their daily routine of
having sex
city leaders are begging the federal
government to send more doses but like
me there's just not enough of the good
stuff to go around
we go to the world's foremost expert for
the latest
dr monkey will you be
does that mean that you won't stand for
any monkey business
doctor can you get monkey pox from bars
what about monkey bars
oh doctor should i wear a condom if i go
to the zoo
dr drew i was kidding you are america's
doctor let's be clear on that first off
two-part question two-pronged question
like that prongs great job thank you
um one
is
monkey pox a legitimate threat or are
they just finding more of it because
they're testing more of it
two is this variant to be worried i mean
there are hospitalizations that have
gone up yeah uh
so there you go seriously first thing i
i think have to these days i have to
sort of define the term doctor okay i'm
the kind of doctor that when they come
up with a loudspeaker in a plane to say
is there a doctor on the plane i stand
up right
you have to say physician now in order
to understand because everybody's a
doctor oh i got you i hear you like dr
jill
so be that as it may uh the monkey box
is serious and the infectious disease
community should be focused on it it
should not be a news story
it should any more than chikumyunga or
any of these other wild illnesses we
have worldwide that infectious disease
doctors are very worried about but
they're not news stories somebody caught
on to it somebody thought it was a
clever story
i'm the only person doing this story
no you're no you're not because it's in
the it's online everywhere all the time
yes it's too much monkey pox it's like i
gotta i see the run down today i'm like
i gotta find something else to say about
monkey pox
because we do this five times a week we
love that chimp thing i do we just love
that we gotta have a reason to do that
that's actually cat
good job
i hope not yeah
but the other thing is the variant now
yes it's a very serious variant it's
highly contagious the r naught of the
alpha and the delta whether it's a three
to five for this omicron ba-5 it's 17.
highly contagious not clear that masks
and do anything for this degree of
contagiousness if you wear an n95 fine
you'll protect yourself you will not
protect other people but you cannot
lower it to eat or drink fluids or
anything like that because you'll get
this thing like that and i've seen
dozens and dozens of cases now and it's
mostly been pretty mild that's yeah
everything's this is the problem tyrus
if you do not dictate the severity of
this thing this could go on forever yeah
they could do this forever yeah just
real quick chicken huberty what did he
do
there's their rift valley fever there's
the brucellosis there's so many valley
fever is that foreign
there's a crimean congo fever there's
always all kinds of stuff out there that
are really serious concerns
that's what caitlyn the point is they
don't they don't contextualize any of it
right there's no context so they just
say this is something you must worry
about
you're so proud of yourself
look at him they know i'm happy for you
it's like the doctor told me yeah he's
so happy yeah they're making fun oh man
you know i'm happy for you no you're not
gonna see you smile yes
uh it's because we don't trust them yes
because they'll never give us even close
to a straight answer they're still
telling us monkey pox is something you
get from the tooth fairy yeah they're
not telling us where you actually can
get these things and how to avoid them
because politically it might not be
correct 9 500 cases in the world yeah
yeah and it's almost exclusively men who
have sex with men that's that and it's
serious for them they should be
vaccinated id should be very concerned
about it it should not be
so to be clear it could be on this show
but not any other news show if you're
not a man
engaging that with sex with other men
very low very low profile okay but they
won't just what you said right there
they will not say
not even a little bit even
our monkey doctor is reluctant to say
that yeah true
well he's planning on running for office
yeah oh that'd be good that's a good
skit yes yes i don't know uh cat i knew
it was hard for you to come up with
something to say no i mean it's the
monkey
i don't know i think it's gonna you're
scratching right yeah exactly
oh hold up though that's not fair that'd
be a weird way for you to find out i'm a
man who has sex with men
shannon how's your uh book women of the
bible
no
no monkey
all kinds of weird plagues and illnesses
and things that are happening boxes upon
your house they would put a box in
somebody's house but remember all of
those are coming at the end of the world
so we should be careful when all this
new stuff keeps showing up hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else